now gentlemen after that station break
we're going downstairs to the busiest
press section in the world positively
this time this is very exciting you must
see this ladies and gentlemen you are
down now in the press room perhaps this
is the first and biggest indication that
we've had of what has happened in 25
years to the Academy Awards
these awards that used to start out as a
little family party a dinner party in
which we honored our own and now with
the press of the world 450
correspondents covering the event of
this kind in Hollywood with it being
beamed around the nation television and
with it being sent around the world that
I radio here you see winners being
congratulated
for the next set of awards I'm going to
turn the stage over to mr. Brackett this
time I wonder if you could make your
applause a little more dignified after
all back east mr. Brackett was known as
an upstate er the people around that
neighbourhood I wouldn't say they
resented Christopher Columbus but they
did think it was bit cheeky of him so if
possible would you please all a pardon
latin the president of the Academy mr.
Charles Breck
to present the award for the best
foreign language film it is a pleasure
to welcome back two-time Academy Award
winner Louise Reiner
Jacque Bergerac will accept the award
for the best foreign language film which
goes to a French picture that stark in
New England of wartime childhood
forbidden games
thank you thank you